[Applause]
how does taylor think this podcast is
amigos song bro
it's like every few minutes you make
love cat love cats
what are these ad-libs yo period
taylor's wild like
the first hour period dale is in and at
the end you just go off the radar oh my
god
i know oh my gosh that's right speaking
of snakes
can we talk about tigers yo oh
all right so tiger started an
real talk
so bad so that was the dumbest [ __ ]
invention that ever happened no but the
[ __ ] flew off the cliff on the
segway and then it stopped oh is that
his
yeah why did he jump off his own device
because he was so embarrassed by a
stupid-ass invention
i really hate that like when the atkins
guy got a heart attack
yeah that's rough that's rough remember
that the guy was like yo you can eat
hamburgers every day and you don't gain
any weight
and then died of a heart attack and now
we just the same [ __ ] as keto right
it is it's the same [ __ ] basically yeah
can't do the cheese on the burger that's
it
yeah you can on keto i don't know
anything
i don't know
instead of no easy buckets i don't know
anything i don't know anything i said
rhinosaur earlier today
it is what it is okay go on what were
you saying
son i forgot i'm gay we were talking uh
taylor brought up tiger's dick oh yeah
so tiger got a mallet
yeah have you seen this thing yeah i saw
that [ __ ] bro
the thing that bothers me about it is
he's holding it in the i got a little
dick position
he's trying to like make the most of his
dick
that you could just grab don't they
i really think it's the angle yeah wait
go that's not the one i saw
that's not that that's that's that
doesn't look small yeah that one kind of
looked
i saw a different one dude i think it's
average at best you saw this one it's
not a different one
what are you talking about guys no that
one's totally little what are you
talking about
nice [ __ ] is huge to me let me see oh
this is not the dick
it is but i think go with this angle
because this one looks crazy
i love how like gold
go with that angle and put that one up
and then make it take the whole picture
yeah but if you're pretending to have a
huge dick and you don't ain't that don't
that
like exactly tip like that's tiger right
there in one picture
i'm gonna pretend i got a huge dick and
i don't that's tiger's entire life
yes there is some like faking but from
what i see
that [ __ ] dick right there it's
the angle
nah that [ __ ] dick right there
wow
who's bigger is the far easier tigers i
don't know i got to see them next to
each other
wet
this guy
market right they put a little moisture
on it looks bigger yo is that why they
do that yeah they got the perfect
i could just want animals the whole
jungle
get out of here safari got two e's that
[ __ ] is so big
amazing but wait a minute that's far
ahead dick about the supermarket
we should be taking our dick pics next
to the fruits
do you know what i mean because it looks
so much more delicious with the perfect
lighting and the
moisture oh yeah you ever get catfished
by the fruit
oh absolutely you take it back to your
house yeah i go what is this shitty
fruit that i bought it's the lighting it
was so nice of the store when they
sprayed the little
little spring spritz on it that's what
we need to do now that's the dick right
there
he has a nice head yo
taylor girl yeah stop objectifying us
like that
comment on that but yeah you're looking
at a dick yeah but we're looking at it
differently looking at a dick
i'm trying to decide how big this part
of his thumb is so i can add him up to
figure out the whole length
yeah because he's just got the bottom of
his thumb at the base
i really think it's the angle really
yeah yeah you been
have you been fooled by a dick pic
before um
by clever lighting on a dick pic clever
angles
not like all right take that [ __ ] yeah i
know
yeah see if you can send me that on my
phone yeah he took down kylie with that
[ __ ]
yeah it's not that big ray j took down
kim with that this this microphone is
bigger than tiger's
nose look at this thickness look at the
thickness of this mic
thickness maybe we're talking about
length distance this is the same
no what are you taylor you're how tall
are you you can't take that
yes i can nah chill out come on don't
get hurt
you're gonna get hurt that's gonna be in
your life i prefer on this side
no way you take a dick that big you have
forrest whitaker's eyes
that's just gonna hit you right in your
socket real talk it's gonna hit you
right in your socket you need to be
careful
this is this is actually a really nice
size uh-uh no
stop stroking it like this that's wild
brutality yo
yeah she's just touching the top of it
chill out black lives matter yours
included stop putting them big old
[ __ ] dicks in you that's crazy
that's really crazy taylor you're making
me feel uncomfortable next topic oh my
god
what else we got yo weinstein still
catching bodies
yeah yo weinstein more women have come
out to say that he
assaulted them or raped him or whatever
like that yeah you late [ __ ] yo
what's going on been there done that
[ __ ] give us a new guy
yo but what is the what is the thinking
with this do you think are you gonna add
more years to his life sentence that he
gonna get
but why come out now uh i mean
he's in jail now right well he's gonna
go to trial but why why do you think
come out now
he's cathartic in some way is it
possible but
oh so they're like i need to get in on
that chatter maybe
and if you saw weinstein's dick you're
entitled to money and again i'm not
saying these i'm not violating
is there is do we have a picture of his
dick
no i don't think we want to see it to be
honest it looks like it
felt like he'll just he's born with
herpes almost there's some wild [ __ ]
about his dick i forget what it was but
there was some wild [ __ ] about no it's
epstein's look like an egg the old egg
dick
no there's some watching about wine
scenes too i don't know what it was but
yeah it's like
these [ __ ] wild dicks are some
rapists bro and that kind of makes sense
nobody would want to consensually [ __ ]
me yeah because i have this disgusting
dick
but is that how dick works keep going
keep going i'm listening mark mark i'm
listening
i'm gonna keep going not even weird to
me is like
if you have a dick that's weird and
you're hooking up with a girl
and she comes back consensually
everyone's happy you take your dick out
and it looks weird
is she just going to leave yeah i would
assume so i mean
if you let me dig work hypothetically
speaking
let's just say you go down on a girl
right and [ __ ]
looks crazy like what like
she stands up and it kind of unfolds
like a beach chair
okay okay what would you do a sleeping
bag that unwrapped
unwraps completely
[Laughter]
i don't know like out of respect i'd be
like i will
we'll just get it done yeah i would say
i have like a like a tonsil issue and i
can't go down son even if you pulled out
he got caught in the [ __ ] webs and
then slid back into wherever
you know i mean he got a little forest
whitaker
yeah you could still beat it up you
could still beat it up absolutely
you still and i would 100 that's what
i'm saying if i'm at that point i'm
gonna cross the finish line i just i
truly don't think i would have the
courage to be like nah i have to leave
like what like because you would be so
concerned that it would make that person
feel
yeah like like they're destroyed they're
at your place you have to like kick them
out you'll be like sorry you just have
to go home now
what if who would do that what if they
showed you
yeah have you ever done that yeah
hold on explain what's going on
a here a girl showed you her vagina
so not look but it smelled a little
funky and i was like that's different
no that's a deformity no we didn't say
it we didn't say we used to form all the
time
we didn't say weinstein's dick smells we
said it looked weird
yes purely off the physicality
you would reject the woman no that's no
you won it you probably turned it around
from the back and hit it mm-hmm
not it was one time i was with a chick
and her vagina kind of felt like an
[ __ ]
it was weird because it was just tight
right at the beginning and then it
opened up in the middle
yeah yeah yeah it was it was weird and
yeah i stopped [ __ ] and
that's it yeah i was in that same
situation but i did not stop [ __ ] at
all i stopped i finished now
it was too weird it was like tight and
then nothing
it was tight at the brim yes how did you
finish it yeah it's like a quarter water
you never [ __ ] a quarter warner
no i
come on alex you're my cinnamon apple
dude
what's a quarter water oh he's doing
recording
25 gum huh you never got a 25
pack of gum neither oh you said gum what
about 50 sell that's what you do in the
quarter one
you know 50 sodas no i know bro
i could use context to put together
money
i'm not asking if you remember because
we've been like
what could it be how much was that how
much is arizona
oh a dollar 25 oh no no
saved it no you was right no it was
actually a dollar
so you're wrong it was 99 family oh yeah
but but
nobody's
come on
you